l'examen est ce que est ce qu'on peut
faire un truc ça rigolait voilà on ce
qu'on peut faire un truc est ce qu'on
peut faire une petite barque à je te
fais la musique de la musique des
ringards tintin dont c'est la question
qu la question où il ya quelque chose de
bon en attendant lui d'ailleurs m est ce
que tu peux pas nous faire imaginons
voilà qui est ta femme dans le lit tu
arrives tu rentres tu rentres dans le
champ et tu nous fais un petit strip 6
avec tout va bien merci
castaldi castaldi castaldi captation
vasic à l'oreiller mois le troisième
c'est bio auriez alecka stallone iba 8 1
la taute one of us fois sensuelle
vaginaux b allez va dire regardez bien
regarder le pape a d'abord lent mais qui
les commandent à bordeaux mais laborieux
au d'abord le haut bah oui paris puis je
me suis pas dit s'il enlève tout de
suite le bas prix mais on l'a mise la
musique t'inquiète pas
t'inquiète pas
viau mais non
lotus r ouais
[Applaudissements]
bravo casta ah bah voilà barazi remettez
la musique ans la blonde
ah oui pas mal à l'épée une petite danse
ma voix basse et génial qu'on peut
l'aborder bravo bravo mathieu mathieu
est ce que toi tu peux nous montrer ce
que c'est la sensualité s'il te plaît
m'ont battu voilà monte revient là je
suis dans deux trucs là mais ce n'est
pas là toi t'as pas beaucoup n'a pas
besoin de beaucoup d espace je sais que
tu fais et je sais tu fait des
merveilles dans des espaces très réduits
donc vas-y fais toi allez vas-y votre
nous alors montre nous montre nous que
c'est quelle attention une crise a dit
mathieu alors mettons un peu bête ouais
la crs de ben ouais pas mal de temps
[Applaudissements]
ouais ouais ouais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est sec
[Musique]
j'ai pas mal calé bravo de protéger j'y
retourne le meilleur pour le marier à la
meilleure la meilleure danse de maison
la mairie meilleures frites il gît là
toi j après ce sera les filles vous dis
tout de suite
dans des temps mr pas t'en as pas
déshabiller n'était pas chez lui fait
pas peur mais nos justes la danse à
wayne est quand même c'est beau c'est
beau mais c'est pas mal hein alors les
deux juges sophie qu'étant parole à la
libre activité des dodos de fans la
ville évalue les mecs et où il a 55 on
le garde
même le corps qui l'a nommé s'avance
évangile ces mots qu'elle me toile était
bon merci je loue merci voilà c'est
familial c'est bien
merci hincker panique en disant ça va
être pour ma gueule dans deux minutes à
mai alors je vous le dis valérie bénaïm
allez c'est parti
non cette annonce vas-y valérie et après
y aura sophie beydon y soit notre gueule
haye pesnel copie montre lui comment tu
fais une panique contre lui après
bellinzone qui fait dépendre mois sauf
sophie va te montrer ce que c'est voilà
et après tu pas la regarde voilà servis
dans des 90 yens la danse à tisser la
danse de voies d'eau 90
non mais c'est pas est ce que vous êtes
l'homme est ce que vous avez vu les
garçons dans ses assises annuelles
les garçons les gnomes et on n'a pas de
molette se met à poil mais les garçons
ont donné
franchement fait une petite danse comme
si vous arriviez voilà fait souvent
sexuelle et sensuelle à votre ado assis
là
vaginale attend d'abord sophie d'abord
sophie davant fait bien mieux qu'une
tente en fait oui non mais sophie sophie
sophie jeter feria ton mec est accrochée
sur le livre vient de l'ong est là qui
va le retrouver le soir tu arrives dans
la chambre et tu te dis je lui faire une
petite danse ou font dire à zoug finir
pierre séparer du territoire
bon alors là il va se marier
maintenant et sensuelle soupire
philosophe dit c'est pas toi ma vie
un guide pour cela non non mais n'allez
pas contre le fait que la banque s'il
vous plaît on ce canal on se pousse
faites-moi vêtements rentrée fait voir
entrer la marocaine a vraiment montré ce
que c'est allé non mais elle a marocaine
en mai sans rigolant dirait qu'elle
ramène du couscous garbit mais sur
l'économie mais sans déconner l'espoir
aussi à dire est qu'elle a un style
assez sensible voir comme ça je tenais
pas il va le chercher ce que tu as une
boulette nommés sont immolés la
connaissance humaine sa mailing sa femme
et l'autre c'est de l'autre scène
planche à pain et l'autre signe boulègue
frère
sans déconner le négoce les deux frères
entre les deux du pas choir map ita
frère c'est un truc de fou voilà qu'elle
rattrape